en este vídeo lo que vamos a hacer es
familiarizarnos con los números
negativos y también aprender un poco de
cómo sumarlos y restar los así que bueno
cuando yo por primera vez vi este tipo
de números me parecen algo misteriosos y
extraños algo muy abstracto porque me
preguntaba yo okay qué significado tiene
un número negativo en si una idea muy
general es que un número negativo es un
número menor que cero entonces lo pongo
aquí un número negativo es un número
menor que cero eso es lo que debe
cumplir y tal vez te parezca algo
extraño abstracto pero simplemente lo
puedes pensar en un contexto diferente
ajá por ejemplo la temperatura y la
temperatura puede ser en grados celsius
o fahrenheit no importa eso pero digamos
que estamos trabajando con un grados
celsius y aquí voy a dibujar una escala
aquí está cero grados celsius un grados
celsius dos grados celsius y tres grados
celsius
ahora bien digamos que
un día bastante frío y que estamos a 3
grados celsius estamos aquí ahora
alguien te dice alguien que predica el
futuro te dice ok sabes algo la
temperatura mañana va a bajar otros
cuatro grados entonces entonces el día
siguiente será cuatro grados más frío si
bajaremos un grado llegaríamos a dos
grados celsius y si llegáramos a si
bajamos dos grados llegaríamos a un
grados celsius
si bajamos tres llegaríamos a cero
grados celsius pero estamos bajando
cuatro así que falta otro más aquí
entonces bajamos otro grado y llegamos a
esto y en este caso aquí aquí este es el
número llamado menos uno puedes ver que
si avanzas a la derecha de la recta
numérica a la derecha del cero
tienes números positivos y si avanzas a
la izquierda del cero tienes números
negativos estos son los famosos números
negativos y estos números negativos cada
vez crecen osea tienes aquí
números negativos cada vez más grandes
pero quiero dejar algo en claro este por
ejemplo ok este menos 3 es un número
menor es menos que menos 1
hay menos calor en el aire con menos 3
que con menos 1 hace más frío al menos 3
que que con menos 1 o por ejemplo ok
menos 100 es un número mucho menor mucho
menor que menos 1 entonces menos 100 es
un número mucho menor que menos 1 y tal
vez tú veas el 100 y el 1 y tú pienses
que menos 100 es un número mucho mayor
que menos 1 pero pero menos 100
significa que hay menor cantidad de algo
entonces con temperatura menos 100 es
más frío que menos 1 otro ejemplo otro
ejemplo digamos que en mí no en mi
cuenta de banco tengo yo 10 pesos así
que digamos que hoy yo tengo 10 pesos
y supongamos que gasto yo salgo a la
calle al parque o lo que sea y gasto 30
pesos ajá gasto 30 pesos
también supongamos que el banco está
todo dar y me permite gastar más de lo
que tengo de hecho eso sí existe a más y
que gastó 30 pesos como se verá mi
estado de cuenta bancaria
voy a dibujar aquí una recta numérica y
tal vez ya te estés imaginando lo que va
a pasar le voy a deber al banco le voy a
deber entonces mañana como se verá mi
estado de cuenta si yo tengo 10 pesos y
gastó 30 ahí hay 20 pesos que que deben
salir de algún lugar cierto y esos 20
pesos salieron del banco entonces le
debería al banco 20 pesos así que en mi
cuenta bancaria para mostrar cuánto
tengo lo que voy a hacer es restar 10
pesos menos 30 pesos
eso me da menos 20 pesos mañana tendré
menos 20 pesos ahora cuando yo digo
tengo menos 20 pesos significa que debo
al banco ni siquiera tengo 20 pesos lo
que lo que tengo es una deuda una deuda
al banco esto va en reversa así que
tengo 10 pesos para gastar aquí pero
después tengo ahí 10 pesos para para
gastar pero ahora debo al banco va en la
otra dirección y si usamos la recta
numérica
aquí ya tendrá más sentido esto yo tengo
aquí inicio con 10 pesos y después gasto
gasto 30 va en esta dirección a la
izquierda si gasto simplemente 10 tengo
cero pesos si gasto otros días tengo
menos 10 pesos y si gasto otros 10 tengo
menos 20 pesos así que si yo gasto 10
llegó a cero si gasto otros 10 llegó a
menos 10 si gasto otros 10 llegó a menos
20 y toda esta distancia todo esto es lo
que yo gasté gaste 30 pesos ahora la
idea general con los números negativos
es moverte a la izquierda en la recta
número
los números se hacen cada vez más
pequeños incluso se hacen más pequeños
que cero esa es la idea general es decir
mientras más avanzas en la dirección
hacia la izquierda más pierdes y si
estuvieras sumando o recibiendo un pago
entonces te mueves a la derecha en la
recta numérica y ya con esto dicho
hagamos unos ejercicios puramente
matemáticos
pensemos pensemos qué significa si
digamos yo tengo 3 menos 4 esto aquí es
igual
esto es análogo a lo de la temperatura
cierto iniciamos en 3 y restamos 4
entonces nos movemos 1 2 3 4 espacios
hacia la izquierda y llegamos a menos 1
ahora cuando haces esto más seguido
empiezas a entender que es un número
negativo y te recomiendo que visualice
es la recta numérica y te muevas en ella
qué te parece si hacemos más ejemplos a
qué te parece
2 - 8 ajam entonces otra vez pongo la
recta numérica esto es lo más
recomendado pongo la recta numérica y
aquí está el 0 no de hecho de hecho no
mejor lo voy a poner un poco más ya sea
a la derecha
tenemos 1 y 2 y estamos restando 8
entonces nos movemos 8 pasos hacia la
izquierda aquí es 1 aquí es 2 y llegamos
a 0
y todavía nos falta un buen recorrido
cuántos pasos nos quedan seis pasos
entonces de 0 1 2 3 4 5 y 6 qué número
es este veamos aquí tenemos el 0 después
menos 1 - 2 - 3 - 4 menos 5 y menos 6
entonces 2 menos 8 es igual a menos 6
esto es igual a menos 6
aquí tenemos 2 menos 2 es igual a 0 pero
estamos restando 8 entonces todavía
recorremos más hasta llegar al menos 6 6
pasos hacia la izquierda del 0 voy a
hacer otro ejemplo entonces este tal vez
te parezca un poco extraño pero ok qué
te parece
- 4 - 2 iniciamos en un número negativo
esta vez y restamos todavía más así que
la recta numérica no lo olvides
y aquí tenemos el 0 el menos 1 - 2 - 3 y
menos 4 ahí vamos a empezar así que al
menos 4 le vamos a restar 2 nos movemos
2 pasos hacia la izquierda en 1 llegamos
a menos 5 y nos movemos otro y llegamos
a menos 6 entonces menos 4 menos dos es
igual a menos 6 y ahora hagamos un
experimento vamos a iniciar esta vez con
un número negativo menos 3 pero en lugar
de restar vamos a sumar sumamos 2
entonces nos movemos 2 pasos hacia la
izquierda ajá si nos movemos 1 llegamos
a menos 2 y después nos movemos otro
paso más y llegamos a menos 1 por lo
tanto menos tres más dos es igual a
menos uno y ahora puedes ver que esto
cumple con las reglas tradicionales de
suma y resta cierto si tú iniciasen
menos 1
2 llegas a menos 3 es como el reverso y
menos tres más dos es igual a menos 1 -
1 - 2 es igual a menos 3 si tu inicias
en menos 1 y restas 2 puedes ver que
llegas a menos 3 ajá espero esto te dé
una idea de lo que es un número negativo
y espero que este vídeo te haya dado una
buena idea de lo que de lo que es y cómo
se suman y restan de hecho vamos a ver
más ejemplos en vídeos posteriores